i told him to win the game you're gonna
have to be mentally and physically uh
exhausted you know to win this football
game
anytime you're you're a man coverage
they're gonna try to to pick and rub you
there's gonna be
gadgets or
throwbacks or whatever there may be
defensively they're going to do things
that are going to force you to think and
ben and ryan and
make calls
we didn't hand them anything and that
that was the one thing that they feast
on bad football we didn't hand them
anything and um
you know i don't think our guys
you know spent too much time staring up
at those banners
mike vrabel head coach of the tennessee
titans after a 20-13 victory that
terminated the terminator intimidated
and you know i'm kind of glad that was a
saturday game and i had an exciting
sunday game between the vikings and
saints because i'm taking less crap from
you today than i thought i was going to
take but i got to give you credit you
were onto it it wasn't just a guess like
some would brush off a correct
prediction there are some out there just
say oh it's just a guess well yeah it is
a guess but it's an informed guest and
we're we're compensated in part to
provide our takes and make an informed
educated guess right slash prediction
and uh you you you focused on the better
team regardless of the mystique yeah and
that's what vrable did right he got his
team ready he knew they were better he
told them how they were going to win and
they went out and they did it they did
uh played clean football you know just
like he said four quarters didn't mess
anything up had a few wrinkles here and
there tannen hill played smart football
for the most part you know they took
julian edelman out of the football game
right things we see new england do to
other teams james white had a little
more success than i expected
uh but i think the big thing to me mike
that jumps out more than anything and i
know you've heard me kind of like bang
the table with this all year long
they're one of the first teams other
than the baltimore ravens i feel like to
go
okay you play a 3-4 defense and one of
your defensive ends which is like and
the 3-4 defense is like a defensive
tackle it's the richard seymour position
it's made for like the hugest human
beings on the planet richard seymour was
6-6
three thirty like one of those guys
you'd walk on the field and go oh my
gosh the guy playing that position now
is dietrich wise he's 270 pounds and
they ran right at him and to me that was
the thing i would you know you've heard
me say it like would somebody take
advantage of them having five
linebackers on the field and stop
letting them off the hook and trying to
throw into these defenses that were made
to play the pass and that's why i think
the best thing the titans did they were
very patient with derrick henry and they
bludgeoned him up front and controlled
the clock and kept brady off the field
for a lot of the time and really uh just
played a real clean football game 182
yards on 34 carries for derek henry and
they really could not stop him and they
knew they weren't going to be able to
stop him and the titans did what they
knew was going to work 15 passes for
ryan tannehill 32 carries right for
derek henry okay yeah the key moment in
the game first half patriots had the
ball first and goal on the one right 13
times right the patriots have had first
and goal on the one in the post season
this is the only time they didn't score
a touchdown wow 12 other times they
punched it that was a huge moment in the
football game because you're just going
uh-oh here we go patriots got them in a
bad spot it's 10-7 they're about to make
it 17-7 and you're going tennessee's not
going to be able to throw the football
consistently and come back on the
patriots so this is getting scary but uh
their first round pick rashad evans from
two years ago out of alabama man did he
make some unbelievable plays the titans
got great size up front but that's the
difference between the patriots this
year this has been a common thing we've
seen not at the one yard line
necessarily but we're used to them
hey
you hold the other team to a field goal
i'm tom brady in the offense we go down
and score a touchdown and they haven't
done that this year in fact in a lot of
the big games it's been the other way
around the other team scores the
touchdown and they end up kicking the
field goal and that was just speaks to
some of the problems that the offense
has had throughout the year how does
this happen that they've allowed the
cupboard to get so bare yeah and
offensive skill talent game breakers
right right i mean they they had to have
had an inkling rob gronkowski was sure
yeah right they they they haven't had a
game breaker on the outside like you
know we just kind of shrug at it like oh
well it happens but bill belichick's the
architect of this roster why why are we
and you know what when you have six
pelts on the wall or pellets on the
horse
when you have that much success you
don't get criticized but i think it's
fair to take a step back and say you
know the the mad scientist
uh had a blind spot for his offensive
talent this year because
uh he's the guy that put the team
together well yeah you know
maybe it's not a blind spot or or but
it's it's a lack of a plan maybe c and d
which we usually see out of new england
they went into the season they realized
they needed help they needed help they
got josh gordon back so i think they
thought okay
and then they put antonio both
to me that's where i was saying they
didn't get to plan c and plan d it's
kind of like they thought okay we got
plan b
and we should be okay with antonio brown
and josh gordon of course yes they have
huge red flags like you're saying and
there just was no plan of attack after
that and then the muhammad's new trade
was a failure it was you know i think we
all expected more out of muhammad sunu
coming from the atlanta falcons should
have gotten emanuel sanders well yeah i
mean yes no doubt about it emmanuel
sanders is clearly more dangerous of a
football player than muhammad sunu is at
this point and yeah i think that you
know hurt them as far as what they
expected out of sunu and sunu really
never got indoctrinated into the offense
i mean think about it the patriots
signed emmanuel sanders to an offer
sheet when he was a restricted free
agent several yeah i was there i
remember dealers matched it right
steelers matched it then a year later he
was going to sign with the chiefs and
something happened he ended up with
denver right and the way the trade
deadline went down
right the 49ers wanted sunu that's
hilarious yes my buddy kyle shanahan and
then they lucked into the fact that the
patriots traded a second round pick and
they weren't willing to do it and it
ended up getting them senior sanders
otherwise it could have been sanders in
new england knows maybe he would have
been enough of a difference yeah well
sanders it still can scare you with the
deep threat you know i think that's the
difference like sunu has lost his
vertical speed to where i think corners
play him and they go okay you know he's
not going to beat me deep so i'm going
to play all the underneath routes and
that's a difficult thing to get open
with as a receiver when you can't back
people off sanders can still back people
off and shanahan runs a number of deep
routes too to go along with it to where
that helps him out but yes they got to
go back to the drawing board in new
england definitely i mean they not so
they need to go back to the drawing
board listen this is still this is a
team that's one or two players away from
we're going oh they're the
and they'd and they would rattle off
they would rattle off we could have
beaten the ravens we could have beaten
the texas we could have beaten the
chiefs we could have beaten the dolphins
i mean they were in every game and then
the brady thing's real too what where do
we go from here i don't know i know
we're going to talk about it more later
but you know again was there weapons
around tom brady no is tom brady allowed
to make a play though without weapons
around him yes and tom brady doesn't
make plays anymore and i know people are
going to go oh you're such a hater sims
whatever i'm waiting for the likes i
know i know but yes you know again if
we're going to hold all quarterbacks to
the equal standard you know again we saw
there's there's other quarterbacks out
there you you know yes he's 42 he's
still doing really good things but he's
not doing anything when the team is at
an average spot right now that you're
gonna go oh brady's got us he'll carry
the squad no so if they decide they want
to go further with brady they got to get
him more support because he's just not
the player he was five years ago where
he could say jump on my back guys i got
us and i think that's going to be a
factor in whether or not the patriots
want him and yeah you could have a split
you could have bill belichick wanting to
move on you could have the crafts
wanting to keep tom brady and robert
kraft told peter king in his uh football
morning in america column that kraft
would prefer that brady either stay or
retire of course obviously it's the jim
irsay mindset from eight years ago he
didn't want peyton manning to play for
someone else you don't want that great
quarterback to go somewhere else and
make you look bad for not having found a
way to keep him and the great
competition will be if tom brady goes to
another team can he win without
belichick and belichick win without him
and uh that will be the tiebreaker as to
who's more responsible for the sixth
championship yeah seriously i i feel
like that's what people are going to
base it on and i hope it happens well it
has nothing to do with that chaos you
know again i want yeah it's more about
one person bill walsh retired from the
49ers and they went 14-2 won the super
bowl joe montana left the 49ers and they
went to three nfc championship games and
then won a super bowl like we all got to
stop putting one person on a pedestal in
all of this too much but uh either way
shocking it was almost like it was cool
because you're like wow tennessee's
gonna win this
i also was sad at the end of the game i
can't lie because i was sitting there
going man is this it like you know hey
i'm sick of talking about new england
too but it was still special and you're
just wondering is this the last time
we're gonna see this dynasty and like
it's such a hey this was a special era
in football the the run that brady and
belichick have made it was sad when the
terminator finally it was you're right
it was sad it was sad but i mean you
know they gave a thumbs up
um we will be talking later about what
tom brady may do what he could do but
tom brady and drew brees in the same
boat tied together they both have passed
peyton manning all-time passing
touchdown mark and both are due to
become free agents and there's a chance
both will be playing for other teams a
long list of veteran quarterbacks
available this year
which may be where the patriots go we
just don't assume it's going to be jared
stidham yeah right and maybe maybe bill
belichick wants himself
to have one of these young mobile
quarterbacks if he can find one look at
how the young mobile quarterbacks do
against the patriots maybe he wants to
you know if you can't beat him join them
well yeah i mean the patriots brady i
mean is mcdaniel's gonna be there is joe
judge the special teams coach gonna be
there i mean you know i just feel like
it seems like people in the new england
organization over the last two years
realize ooh this is the beginning of the
end and they're all trying to find their
new separate life going forward here it
just feels like that i don't know bill
belichick's not going anywhere i know
he's still there but it just it feels
like you know okay the writing's on the
wall that at least we're coming to the
end maybe a bill belichick like we're
down the home stretch of the last maybe
three four or five years of his career
too just feels that way to me
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports